we are here with Alexis Goldstein who
was amazing on the show tonight you are
a lot of fun to watch going toe-to-toe
with Barney Frank which is it's great
because you guys are actually not that
far apart on you know you're working
toward the same issue but you maybe have
different ways of going about it what
was that
papa where did you guys end up on that
well I think we probably agreed about
more than we discussed but you know you
want to talk about the things that you
disagree on and I think that I want
things to go farther I want even more
regulation I think he's more satisfied
perhaps with what's in dodd-frank and
that's understandable it bears his name
sure but I'm a big proponent of the
glass-steagall 2.0 I'm a big proponent
of something called brown bitter which
is about raising capital requirements on
banks so I think we need to push even
harder I don't think it's enough to just
implement dodd-frank so I think that's
probably the main place where we differ
but I think we probably agree very
strongly that dodd-frank is very
important it needs to be finished did
you guys make up after the show and you
leave it on good terms I try I think
yeah we'll see next time mate all right
no it was a fiery exchange so what so
you're involved with the Occupy Network
and what has Occupy been up to lately
not so much camping anymore then yeah
nobody's really put the kibosh on that
babe it's just very very violently but
so the Occupy Network calm is the place
where you can go and sign up for a
mailing list so you can find out about
everything that occupy is doing lately
but there's two things that I'd love to
talk about just because I don't want to
talk about too much oh this is the place
to do it
hahaha so one of them is with this Red
Square that I wore you've got some great
flair going on there it represents a
group called strike debt and they're
basically about organizing around
people that have debt which is pretty
much everyone in this society and the
idea is basically that because social
services continue to be cut in order to
make a living and in order to get all
the things we need we need to take on
tech so it's good education and maybe to
take out a loan to pay a hospital bill
and so dead is the tie that binds the
99% and so strike debt as a bunch of
projects one of them was a little
pamphlet called this debt resistors
operations manual that has a lot of
practical information about how do I
write to a credit rating agency if
there's an error on my credit report how
do I get banking if I have a low credit
score and things like that and then the
other thing that got a ton of media
attention is something called the
rolling jubilee and that sounds like
yeah
biblical you know these in the Bible do
it in England or something right yeah
real briefly on this show but the idea
of the rolling Jubilee is if banks have
decided that borrower is not going to
pay they write off the amount of the
debt on their taxes so they get a tax
write-off so then they get to double-dip
and they get to sell that debt in the
secondary market to a debt collector so
they get to write it off and get a tax
break and then they get to sell it on
the cheap in to a debt collector can I
have that deal yeah you're right so if
that was originally a hundred bucks they
might sell it to a debt collector for
say five bucks but then the debt
collector will call you and how you and
harass you and make you pay a hundred
bucks even though they only paid five so
what the rolling jubilee said is hey
anyone can buy this debt let's have a
talk on let's raise some money and let's
buy this cheap debt and abolish it so
they raise half a million dollars
because that's really cheap they were
able to abolish millions of dollars of
worth of medical bed that's cool so it's
a big kind of way to draw attention to
the sort of shady debt collection I'm
sorry to get people excited about it hey
let's go out and buy some kind of trying
about take the shame away from the idea
of having debt because there's so much
like morality and playing you know we
all kind of need to take on debt these
days there's no shame in it
so that's one project and another big
project is occupy sandy which came about
kind of organically after than a
hurricane hit and we rallied 60,000
volunteers what we did is we went on
into the communities long before the Red
Cross and FEMA got there we went up into
buildings that had no power no heat up
to the elderly residents apartments they
were trapped up there elevators didn't
work and we said what do you need this
is a concept known as mutual aid and
it's distinguished from charity because
charity is like I know what you need
here Rachel Aid is tell me what you need
maybe I have it and so we went out and
we did all this polling and then they
used they did a clever thing they used
in amazon.com wedding registry and they
put all the things that were needed on
the registry so anyone around the
country could buy diapers or head lamps
or shovels or you know masks are
clearing mold and so there were 750
thousand dollars worth of supplies that
were purchased through that registry and
sent out to these affected communities
and what's happening now is the hardest
part which is the restore and rebuild
portion so they're working out in the
Rockaways to try and do worker owned
coops to help rebuild and help people
you know rebuild green and so that's
ongoing
so occupy sandy net is
place where you can find out about that
but yeah message involved right check it
out occupy network.com occupy sandy net
and strike that org get into it Alexis
thank you so much thank you for having
will hope to see you again soon I'd love
to come back all right thanks